[Musique]
si yann liénard du président de l'ast et
sur la cavalerie qui vous présente ici
donc ces animaux et notamment les
chameaux et dromadaires donc cette
association elle a pour but premier de
faire découvrir les camélidés en france
et en plus de ça du coup la caméra
décidé de faire partager aussi les
connaissances sur d'autres animaux
[Musique]
alors leurs fusils et donc une vache qui
est une vache africaine donc on peut la
retrouver dans la savane en fait en
train de vivre avec les girafes les airs
comme nous la vache chez nous elle peut
être consommée elle peut être
elle est en fait un animal de production
peut en manger et boire sans sa
particularité ici ce qui est assez
sympathique
c'est que en fait elle à des normes
cornes donc ils peuvent mesurer jusqu'à
un mètre trente chaque corne
particularité c'est quand on en fait
elles sont vides
donc pour la vache ça va pas être
insupportable à la portée parce que ça
ne sort pas du coup trop lourd ici en
france il ya un animal domestique
donc tout simplement pour le plaisir de
cette vache et pour l'aca bonne
compagnie donc ici c'est vraiment une
vache qui a été élevé à trimer avec nous
qu'avec une à la maison début de sa vie
qu'ils veulent et des biberons de toutes
les nuits on a créé un lien avec cette
vache et il a vraiment fait vraiment
partie des mêmes familles possédant de
la compagnie à 100%
[Musique]
la rotonde noir et blanc qu'il a la tête
tout noir le corps entièrement blanc
c'est donc un mouton qui a besoin de
très peu de nourriture parce qu'en
somalie va dans le désert du coup trouvé
très peu d'alimentaire et donc sa
particularité de ce fait c'est qu'il va
avoir comme chez le dromadaire observons
une pause une boule de graisse sur
l'arrière train on a juste au dessus de
l'accueil qui va lui permettre du coup
de survivre quand les conditions sont
difficiles
ils ont vu aucune destination à la
boucherie
c'est vraiment que l'animal de compagnie
est ce que c'est un moto atypique voyez
pour ne pas avoir la même chose que tout
le monde on ferme ton différent
[Musique]
ici on a des jeunes qui font moins d'un
mètre on est sur 90 cm voire moins pour
certains c'est un animal qui va
globalement servir à rien de plus qu'à
la compagnie parce que on peut même pas
monter sur son dos c'est vraiment annan
qui va pas avoir un dos solide comme un
âne du cotentin où un baudet du poitou
on est vraiment sur quelque chose qui va
manger l'herbe de la pelouse parce que
pour entretenir un terrain parce que
c'est plus sympa de la tondeuse c'est
plus écologique et parce que cette
champagne aux enfants comme on l'a fait
chez les chiens qui sont devenus du coût
des petits chiens temps les chihuahuas
claira c'est vraiment des croisements de
des plus petits spécimens qu'on pouvait
trouver de la race pour en faire une
race du coup vraiment petit
[Musique]
et la particularité aussi de ce début
c'est que comme le mouton somalie le
dromadaire ou de chameaux il a aussi une
bosse donc ici partant d'une tour
somalie sur l'arrière train mais sur les
épaules comme le dromadaire si je puis
dire
qui va là aussi lui permettre du coup de
survivre lorsque les conditions sont un
peu difficiles
donc c'est toujours de la grèce chez
tous ces animaux là c'est de la grèce il
n'y a pas d'eau dans les bosses de la
grèce qui va transformer en nutriments
soit en eau en fonction de ses besoins
c'est une vache noire trouvés dans la
nature notamment en armes d'avoir du sud
or jane aussi et là bas notamment c'est
ce qu'on connaît comme la vache est
temps la vache sacrée
c'est là le début qui est la base ça
écrire en armes
[Musique]